by good evening
everyone welcome
to the executive committee 8th of
February
2024 welcome
to members of the public who are
attending welcome
members item one apologies for absence
although first I better do the e
evacuation
announcement there are no planned fire
drills so if the alarm goes off please
leave the building in an orderly fashion
through the nearest fire
exit please use the fire exit through
the main doors of the hall or the fire
exit in the store room adjacent to the
stage the fire assembly point is the
island in front of the main entrance of
the
building please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not return to the
building until given permission to do so
by Council
staff please switch off mobile phones or
turn them to
silent please note that the meeting will
be live
streamed and for members please ensure
your microphone is switched on when
speaking and you speak clearly into to
the
microphone we have members of the public
present so I must ask you members of the
public and
press whilst you are of course entitled
to film or take photographs during this
meeting can I can I please emphasize to
you that this should only be done
without disruption to the meeting and
can only be done from a designated area
in the public seating
can I please therefore ask you to raise
your hand clearly in the air if you wish
to take photographs or film this
evening no hands are up so we are now
clear to move to the agenda item one
apologies for
absence I have an apology from counselor
Jim
KPS are there any
others no
item two non-members
attending there are
none item three minutes of the meeting
held on the 25th of January 2 and
24 members can I sign this these as a
true and Fair View of the meeting that
was held on that date yep any know other
matters to arise
I will sign them thank
you item four to receive Declarations of
interest there are
none item five questions on notice from
counselors there are
none item six matters referred to the
executive and reports from
committees there are
none item
seven item seven is the 2
2425 budget and
2429 medium-term Financial strategy
report I intend to ask lead member
councelor Michael
Hoy to lead on this item and present for
members thank
you thank you
chairman the EXA oh sorry I'll just take
some that's better the executive on the
25th of January referred the budget and
medium-term financial strategy to the
overview and scrutiny committee that
committee met on 1st of February and
agreed a recommendation which is
presented to this executive tonight in
addition to this the government issued
its final local government financial
settlement on 5th of February the impact
on Rochford 202 2425 budget as compared
to the provisional settlement built into
the report is to Grant an additional
114,000 to The
District in light of this I propose that
£25,000 be earmarked to enable
consultation with
residents and consultancy in respect of
regeneration of r
regarding the options for South Street
and Freight
House I further propose that the balance
of
89,000 be added to Capital funding which
will help bridge the 20242 funding Gap
outlined in the report on page
9.12 I hope that this executive will
consider these proposals and revise its
proposed budget and mtfs to the for
Council on 20th of February subject to
this and the executives discussions on
the feed feed back from on I propose the
recommendations which are set out on
page 7.11
7.2 you want me to read those proposals
now or later uh thank you m councilor ho
I'll just ask if um um Mr Willis interim
director of resources has anything he
wishes to add no but I'm happy to answer
any questions thank you chair members
before we move to the recommendations
are there any questions you have for
councelor Michael Hoy or
Mr Tim Willis thank
you ask question I looks like
um councilor Newport is ready
go thank you chairman um if I may for
you chairman ask councilor Hoy um the
proposed budget of
25,000 for
consultation um can I just
clarify at what point the details of
that consultation will
be
um sort them through
which lead member
thanks the scoping for the consultation
hasn't yet been decided I would expect
that to go through the executive with
the assistance of um Mr wi and um M
fox
and assets I was going to add counc H
that I I would appreciate the um the
input of Phoebe B in this particular
matter as who is leading the um
strategic asset program as well so thank
you very
much there are
no further questions put
councilor Hoy has
outlined proposals
for changes
to the draft report turning it into a
recommendation of a report to for
Council Council Hoy if you'd like to
proceed with reading the recommendations
I'd be
grateful thank you
chairman the recommendations are set on
page 7.1 7.2 um item
two
recommendation so it is proposed that
the executive recommends to council that
it resolves R1 that the 20242 budget and
20 2429 medium-term Financial strategy
for both revenue and capital are
approved R2 that the section 51 officer
be authorized to adjust Capital project
budgets in
20242 after
2023 24 accounts are closed and the
amounts of slippage and budget carried
forward required are confirmed R three
that the increase in Rochford district
council tax of
£755 for a band D property
2.99% for 20242 is approved by recorded
vote R4 that the proposed council tax
requirement for the council's own
purposes excluding parish and town
councils and precepts for 20242 is
8583 million is
noted are for that the statement of the
robustness of the estimates and Reserves
at section 14 is
noted
so there the recommendations which we
are approving to go to full Council
thank you councilor Hy um you are moving
those recommendations to be put do I
have a second there please
councelor EES is
seconding right I'm now going to put all
of those R1 to
R5 together as a vote do you approve of
that okay in which case I will ask for a
for votes please show of hands those who
are in favor of recommendations R1 to R5
to full
Council
looks pretty unanimous to me from those
present thank
you that
completes item
seven item
eight item eight is the Q3 budget
monitoring
report
2024 and again I have um councelor
Michael is very busy this evening he's
going to um present that budget
monitoring report please thank you thank
you chairman so this is the quarterly
quarter 3 budget monitoring report um
the report sets out the latest
monitoring position for The Current
financial year it forecasts a £240,000
underspend against the revised Revenue
budget this underspend has been built
into the revenue assumptions in the
budget and mtfs Report it further
forecasts a 2.5 million underspend on
the capital program against the revised
program of 6.1 million as set out in
appendix 3 I propose the executive that
this report be
noted thank you councelor Hoy can I ask
whether any members have any questions
for um councilor Hoy or indeed Mr Willis
please
looks to me there are none in which case
I will move from the chair that this
report be noted do we all agree noted
thank
you item
nine item nine is the joint Leisure
procurement strategy to consider the
report of the executive League member
for leisure tourism and well-being uh C
councelor Julie
Gooding councelor Gooding I'm going to
invite you to present your report thank
you very
much thank you chair um the purpose of
this procurement strategy is to set out
the council's approach to the
procurement process establish a balance
to meeting the council requirements
whilst making the opportunity attractive
to the
market set out a clear strategic
direction for the development of the
contract and procurement
documents in the Strategic objectives
our focus on delivering a financial
sustainable Services service improve
physical and mental health and
well-being of our
residents with a high quality Innovative
services and supporting the council Net
Zero carbon
Ambitions the Strate the strategy is
based on a joint contract with Brentwood
B Council IL which will enable us to
jointly procure an operator for leisure
services for both councils which will
improve the financial position through
economies of scale it makes the offer
attractive to operators by promoting a
large market share in South Essex and
improves the quality of service to our
residents the report sets out the
benefits as well as the perceived risks
of procuring jointly in detail the
Leisure working group has received has
reviewed the benefits risks and
mitigating action of joint procurement
the working group are recommending this
strategy to the executive for
approval thank you chair thank you
Council
Gooding um I'd like to ask whether
Phoebe bars or Mark Alis would like to
add anything to the presentation that's
been given
nothing to add but we're both happy to
take any
questions thank you um in which case
members the floor is open for questions
so go get
it councel Mrs nle thank
you thank you
chair um I may have over overlooked it
but I do believe it was said at one
point about the energy tariff can you
confirm what the setup is going to be
with regards to the energy tariff
[Music]
please yeah thank you for the question
um so the proposal within the strategy
um is that there's a uh shared risk with
the energy tariff moving forward so the
the current arrangement with the current
Leisure operator is they've got foral
responsibility um for energy consumption
energy tariffs um but the advice we've
been given is that um operators may not
bid if they're um with a kind of
uncertainty around energy tce operators
may not um bid if they're required to
take on full responsibility so the
mechanism that we we put in place is
that um the operator would have full
responsibility for consumption um but
when it comes to the Tariff um uh they
would have responsibility up to a a
certain point linked to inflation and
then anything above that would become
the responsibility of the council um the
danger of not doing that would be if
Energy prices did actually drop during
the term of the the contract um then we
could end up the council could end up
paying kind of a higher high amount
within the management fee than would
otherwise be the case they wouldn't have
any benefit from that so that's the
proposal put forward but yeah has been
we have been advised that some operators
may not bid if they were asked to take
on for
responsibility back yes please thank you
chair and what's the benefit of that for
the council at the end of the day
financial benefit will we gain from that
if the energy prices fall
so if the um operator had full
responsibility they would obviously
build that into the into the management
fee so therefore if there was
subsequently a drop in Energy prices
then um the council wouldn't benefit
from that but if we um with the system
that you said where the council cover a
certain amount of the energy if the
energy tariff then Falls say we I don't
know so we're going to pay a th they're
going to pay ,000 pound a month and the
bills 15500 a month so the council's
putting £500 a month if the Tariff Falls
and it's they they're not having to pay
£1,000 a month do we get any of that
money back is what I'm trying to ask
yeah no I understand the question i'
have to seek clarification on that
you um so to answer your point yes there
would be a benefit so we The Proposal is
as Markus highlighted out so there would
be a cap and around consumption so the
purpose of anything being consumed over
the cap subject to inflation would then
be allow us to push back on consumption
so if energy rates were to fall and then
the consum then the operator would pick
them up and there'll be less of a
financial pressure to us as marks quite
rightly pointed out if we don't go down
that route what biders will do is
they'll build the risk into their
management fee so actually by going out
and procuring at this stage our
management fee should be less and they
where will to manage the risk of
inflation and utility costs through the
contract rather than being stuck with a
higher management fee from the
offset okay thank
you thank you Council
standing thank you chair
um just to ask that should we improve
the
uh the building in any
way would that will will we refund will
we get the the the money back and not go
to
the management that are doing it in
other words when we if we ever put in
a electric Soul slot solar or heating or
anything like that that would be would
that be down to us to put that in or
would that be the management that will
take it over to put that in and would
would we receive any benefit from that
or would they receive the benefit from
it
so with the proposals we are looking at
options on investment in the building um
and we'll have that open dialogue with
with biders and the purpose of that is
to look at if the council was willing to
put any investment in what additional
Revenue that could generate for an
operator therefore that would then be
built into their management fee so yes
we would get a financial return by
having a reduced management fee payable
to an operator or income coming back
also the purpose of the procur strategy
highlights that um we would look at the
performance on an annual basis on an
open book approach of on the profit and
therefore any profits over and above
would come back into to the council as
well my other question if I may chair um
with both with both assets being
operated by a single
management um will there be any
differential between
what is spent on both properties and
will that
be in comparison or will it be one will
be spent more or or less on the other
one because I do think that maybe there
could be a differential of of finances
going into each property if you could
clarify that thank you yep so um under
the contract each site will
um be the financial perform performance
will be monitored per site so the
expenditure the income will be presented
for each site so one won't cross
subsidize the other we will highlight
what needs investment needs to be made
in each building what incoming
expenditure is expected from each each
site as well so it's one overarching
contract with the detail per site
sitting directly underneath
it so each site will have its own
Financial yes G or whatever the case is
that is correct thank
[Music]
you any other
questions okay councelor Mrs Wilson
thank
you oh hello chair thank you um I'm just
seeking excuse me I'm seeking
clarification I'm going to refer to
appendix 3 and I'm really sorry but
having read appendix 3 I was getting
very
confused
so 9.5 9.4 states that cross party has
five
members
9.49 lists seven
names
9.51 the membership under membership and
frequency states there are six members
9.52 list six names and 9.53 list five
names um so just seeking clarification
as to how many members are on on the
working group I think the names are less
important just I think we just need to
be
um consistent all the way through sorry
thank you councilor Gooding can you
clarify yeah just to clarify for um
councelor um the uh the the working
group consists of uh five members and
there are two members that were put on
there but are no longer on there so did
do you want me to name the two members
that are removed um yes please and I'll
just amend my notes thank you okay so
that's uh councilor Tracy Knight and
councelor Lisa
newort thank
you councel re thank
you thank you chair um bearing in mind
that the uh project is being done over
the two councils and we are looking for
saving there um 6.0 on page 9.8 we're
looking at a uh an allocation of 105,000
pounds there to the
procurement um do I take it that that is
rushford's cont contribution to it and
that brenwood has a similar amount that
they're putting into
it yeah that that 105,000 is for for
Rood alone yes yeah it just seems to me
that if we're looking at quarter million
pounds to allocate a contract that seems
rather
a large amount of money can we justify
that um so jointly procuring the
contract with Brentwood has uh seen
saving so to the UMC the Consultants
that we've um got working with us um
having a joint procurement that's cost
the uh or the cost of the council is
less than it would have been had we um
procured a contract solely as rer
District Council it still does seem like
an awful lot of money for one contract
to be procured that's my opion can I
follow up on that one one assumes I'm
going to ask that um that there was
obviously a competitive uh tender for
the consultancy to provide the
procurement and therefore I hope you're
going to tell me that it was the best
value and more particularly the best
suited to provide that reur can you can
you guide us on that please pH thank you
yeah we did did um we procured the
Consultants the funds allocated are not
NE are not only just for the Consultants
it's also for the legal external legal
support that we will need in writing the
uh contracts producing the tender
documents and the support we need
through the procurement as well it's a
budget we won't spend it if we don't
have to it's just an allocated sums to
allow us to deliver a procurement of
this value and this size because it's a
10-e contract with 5 years plus so it's
a considerable size contract for um for
for the organization so we need to make
sure that we we are doing it right and
the biggest expense will be our legal
support to make sure the contract is
solid do you want to come back on that
Council no I'm fine with that that
answer thank
you yes of course Mark so just to add to
that I mean the Consultants that we are
working with SLC um they wrote the the
guidance um that sport England um have
produced they were the the Consultants
of sporting anded to produce the the
guidance and procuring Ledger contract
so we feel we've got the you know very
good kind of uh advice and guidance and
support through them and I hope the
members of the Leisure working group
would agree that the the meetings we've
had and the guidance that they've given
has been excellent so
far any other questions
members
councelor Mrs newort thank you thank you
chair can I ask on average what is this
what's the saving that we've made by
doing a joint procured contract or
procuring a joint contract do you have a
figure
please um so the um the report that went
to Executive in December um
2022 um outlined a budget of 75,000 for
the feasibility study and procurement um
and the cost of that is around 16,000 um
less than that that budget by jointly
procuring okay thank
you any further questions councelor H
okay yes thank you chairman could um
Miss bars just answer around the reasons
given for not considering an in-house
option there are comments made obviously
around why we can't is this purely down
to a lack of
expertise within the council to to run
these centers or is it
more or is it deeper than that thank
you Fe would you like to update um
councilor Hy um so obviously when the
decision to procure uh an operator went
to the exec on December 22 they
obviously was presented with other
options which are highlighted in section
three of the report on pages 9.5 to
9.6 um and they did look at options of
inhouse and one option one of the issues
is yes we don't we do not have the
resources in house in order to operate
and in house as a service in addition to
that um it'll be the financial cost as
well it will be considerably higher to
what we've got now in the budget that's
promly most a lot of that
is associated with high on cost for
employing staff through a local
Authority with um pension and National
Insurance um which we can't compete with
the private Market because because of
that so um options have been considered
obviously uh we are aware the working
group did discuss looking at in-house
and a further update will be presented
to the executive members on that for
them to make a
decision at a future
okay thank you one further questions um
can I just State for the record that I'm
aware of some of the answers to these
questions but I think it's important I
just raise them in public so people know
that these have been raised that's all
on the second one obviously historically
we've had problems where the contract
which was originally with homes place
was then taken over by virgin Leisure
and then laterally by Fusion can you
just say what the process would be if if
a contract
was simly sold on or moved on to a
different provider which we might not be
happy with I know I've spoken about this
previously so I understand there is an
answer for that thank
[Music]
you um yeah obviously we as was referred
to earlier will be um uh getting
external legal advice in terms of the
drawing up of the contract of the
Leisure contract obviously they will
ensure that but contract um you know
covers that um situation I know um when
the
current contract was novated across to
to Fusion lifestyle those some questions
asked around the contract then but
that's why we're getting external legal
advice um to draw up the contract to
ensure um that there are no issues
moving moving forward with that um I
mean I can't comment on the homes place
to Virgin actives I think that was when
they were brought out by by virgin
active so um couldn't comment on what
the situation would be with a company
being brought out but I think the the
Novation to to Fusion lifestyle is
something we'll ensure is covered with
external legal we
take um I'd like to come in here on that
question if I
may I I assume that within the contract
that the the matter of Novation would be
dealt with and there should be
Provisions in there which are tests upon
uh the proposal which would include in
my
expectation uh the permission and
agreement of the the
councils is that
correct yeah that would be correct and
as Mark point out we are scoping out the
um legal support that we need through
this contract and to address issues like
that I think as well um going forward
with a new contract scoping out all the
issues and making it as as solid as
possible um we're looking at how we
internally contract manage as well so
that when issues arise with the contract
we can deal with them in a relevant
manner quickly um so we can get the
right decision for the organization at
the same
time thank you Council
stav thank you chairman um just one a
couple of things actually have just
sprung to mind in in the way of the way
uh we have actually executed with our
our uh workings with fusion um in as
much as will there be something in the
agreement that as a private
company we won't be supporting them if
they have difficulty in their
finances um which is what which is what
has happened in the past um and also can
I just come in here C Sor would you mind
if I come in here yeah just interject
um I I've had some experience of
commercial contracts and what you will
find in commercial contracts there are
thing called Financial covenants and
therefore that covers the performance
the financial performance and the
financial standing of your operator so
they they will be built into the
contract well that's my opinion I hope
that um Phoebe is going to agree with me
thank you sorry sorry to cut across you
I just thought it would be quicker to
advise you of how those matters are
handled I'm happy with that if you could
continue thank you okay um and my other
question is who will
oversee
the the um if you like the the
management of of the management that we
are going to put on for these two for
this service who is going to oversee it
who is going to be responsible will it
be the working group The Working
committee or who will be uh looking at
the the performance of the of them so I
would expect that the operator would
report to an overview in scrutiny
committee
um on a basis of what was agreed six
monthly or annually but that that would
be my preferen is that the overview and
scrutiny committee would have the
operator report to them so we wouldn't
have somebody that would could actually
go in there and and see if they're
operating in the in the right
performance that we want so from an
operational perspective as an
organization at the moment how it works
is Mark oversees the the contract
management um as as an officer and
reports to me as a director and we have
monthly meetings with the operator and
that would be the same going forward and
we'd build that all into the cont
contract going forward with the open
dialogue with with potential biders that
that is coming up so there'll be an
officer perspective of how we manage the
contract operationally and then from as
suppose a counselor Council perspective
they have the opportunity to scrutinize
and and review the operator through the
ons committee reason that I say this is
that we've done uh James and myself have
done inspection of premises through the
operator that we've got at the moment
moment and we've done that as a if you
like councilors that can go and have a
look at see what's going on and how
things work so I expect the same
operation will work in the
future can I come in
here I'd like to come in and say of
course we'll be operating under a um
committee structure and there will be an
appropriate committee chairman and that
committee chairman is obviously the the
person who um if members wish to make a
a business visit to a Leisure Center
then of course they it would be courtesy
to ask them first and that they may wish
to join that chairman on the appropriate
quarterly or or other type of visit
thank
you any other
questions well I have I want to behave
like Columbo tonight um and another
thing obviously viously in this
procurement and I've read the appendix 3
carefully several times um we are
obviously seeking further
Services additional services for our
residents there are also um changes in
the likely U structure of uh a the
financial side of the contract required
by by
biders and we have the thing we've been
talking about this evening the budget
and obviously this is a contract which
is due to be put in place for April
25 um that means that we need to know uh
as a council as soon as possible just
what the financial impacts are and
proposals are upon the budget for the
25 budget and essentially um I'm going
to ask um Phoebe if she can give me some
idea based on how the project plan is
written when that information is likely
to come available because I'm sure um
that the1 officer and staff will want to
work on that as soon as
possible so based on the project
timeline revised tender submissions are
due to to come in the end of October
this year with evaluation early November
we will be looking to award the
contracts to a full Council in December
ideally to allow for mobilization
therefore all the financials would be um
relayed into Finance at that point in
time so it would be in line with budget
setting for next
year thank you I'm I'm relieved and
we'll be looking forward to seeing that
come forward in the appropriate time
scale any further
questions none okay members thank you
for considering the report asking
appropriate questions of
offices Council Gooding would you like
to consider um putting the
recommendations in the report to the
committee please thank you
chair recommendation one is for Rochford
District Council procures a joint
Leisure operator w brenwood b Council
and recommendation two is to agree the
Leisure working group proposed procured
strategy as per appendix one thank
you so that is moved by counselor Mrs
Gooding seconded
by councelor Mrs
Wilson are you agreeable for having both
recommendations put forward concurrently
voting on together
yeah okay um the recommendations
properly put can I have a vote of those
in favor please show your
hand looks unanimous thank
you thank you
members now move to item nine no item
item 10 is the UK shared Prosperity fund
2024-25
to consider the report of the executive
lead member for resources climate change
and econ economy councelor Michael Hoy
setting out a an approach to
Distributing the council's 2425
allocation from the UK shared Prosperity
Fund in accordance with the already
agreed investment plan
I understand that
um Mr Steve Summers is going to present
the ukbf report to the
committee thank you Steve thank you
chair um so you you're correct this this
is report um sets out a recommended
approach to Distributing the council's
2024 25 allocation from the UK Shar
Prosperity Fund in accordance with its
agreed investment plan um after
consultation with a wide range of
community stakeholders as per the UK SPF
Guidance the council
prioritized the interventions E1 E4 and
e23 in its investment plan the details
of this are set out uh and the funding
Associated funding for all all three
years of of the UK SPF I set out in 211
and 212 of the report on page
10.3 um in addition is recommended
there's two methods of allocating the
funding the first being a community
grant program that's similar to the one
that we um provided last year and the
details of this are set out in appendix
a and then secondly um the the the
second part of that remaining portion of
the allocation is uh funded through
Council Le projects
uh and the summary of the identified
project areas is set out and expanded
upon in appendix P thank you
chair thank you Mr
[Music]
SS I'm going to ask Council Hoy if he'd
like to add anything to the presentation
so far yeah thank you just very briefly
um I thought I've spoken too much
already tonight I just want to draw
people's attention to page
10.17 where we have High Street and Town
Center Rejuvenation Works um as what is
the £100,000 for from the UK SPF fund
there is also sitting in our balance
sheet another £50,000
for High High Street High Street
regeneration which we will also be
looking to distribute as well so in
total we we've got around
150,000 to do to do that work with which
is £100,000 from the UK SPF and 50,000
pounds from our already agreed reserves
thank
you thank you councelor
H councelor re thank you thank you chair
I've got a number of questions around
this um I've taken quite a big interest
in this one of the things that um I am
Keen to uh be insured doesn't happen is
that we spend a huge chunk of this on um
consultants and managements uh sort of
fees and charges uh one of the things
that I'm a little bit concerned about I
must admit is the level of um salary
that we're looking at for employing
someone to look at the uh tourism post
for this particular year um £75,000 when
we're starting from Ground Zero seems
rather a rich uh amount of uh salary for
someone who's coming in from ground zero
to do anything now there may be an
argument there that okay you need that
level of person in to actually bring
that up but um I wonder if it would be
better spent on uh things such as
developing the uh Cherry Orchard uh as
in putting events on now both Julie
Gooding and uh Steve Summers both have
had intense conversations with me around
a lot of the ideas that I've had and
since I've shared those ideas I've had
nothing back at all and they are things
that I think will actually make a big
difference to the offering that this
this actual um Council has or this area
has when you consider that we have a
rich history in this area and it has
never been commemorated we had a um
rather weak offering um a few years back
when we were talking about the
uh uh beagle um and that's had no
lasting uh really effect on the area
which was one of the things that was
actually a project brief for that um and
my concern is that we end up in the same
situation we spend an awful lot of money
on Superfluous stuff and actually don't
end up doing anything so I wonder if we
could have some answers on that please I
I want to interject here because we
we're agreeing the framework tonight
we're not looking at individual
applications uh for uh for for money in
particular you know for things like the
beagle and so forth so I I I just need
to draw that to your attention counselor
is just so we don't run away with um
seeking to distribute the funds tonight
but your questions are noted and I think
councilor Hoy wants to come back on them
there were there were two firstly you
you made the question of you were
concerned that
a significant proportion of the funds
could be spent on
consultancy and in the second case
you've drawn attention to the proposed
salary the proposed costs of you a
permanent employee for the matter of
Tourism correct thank you that's thank
you c h yeah I share councilor Eve's
aversion to consultants for Consultants
sake
um this will not be spent on consultant
could be spent on work um with regard to
the 12mth tourism and events office of
post
with a dedicated budget at the moment
there isn't a there is no resource
effectively in tourism it's whatever
Economic Development can can do in
addition to their normal roles so so
this is not just a a post it's also a
budget and it's and it will be decided
whereabouts that the the role sits with
money and how much budget they will have
to work with and as chairman said this
this is to be decided how that's going
to work later thank
you
so the essentially with that's a budget
figure of £75,000
which isn't necessarily all going to be
directed in the costs of a um limited
post appointment
correct correct do you wish to add to
that no the council is
correct any other questions councelor
councelor Mrs G thank
you thank you chair I we be very brief
but just to as the lead member for
tourism which is the questions that have
been raised um we are meeting on regular
basis regarding the situation on tourism
um now we have members in place we are
building on what was previously done and
we just haven't updated the executive on
what's been going on so I'm quite happy
to take this offline and talk to you
about it does that help
does councelor Gooding it it sounds like
an update's required for the executive
at some point or more more likely the um
the the appropriate committee chairman
needs to take it on board in their work
plan because every as I understand it
every um chair of committee in future
like on will have to have a work plan
set out for the the the work of their
committee for the year so um you may
need to button hole somebody to do that
any further questions
members yes CC standy thank you um
forgive me for asking the question but
am I to understand that the person that
takes on this
role is going to come up with ideas and
and for this
UK SPF whatever that is or is it is it
through a
committee later that
will introduce these and and this is
what's happening I'm not quite I don't
quite understand where this where this
person comes in in in relation to the
the whole
project we have heard that it's um you
know decisions have not been made how
the 75,000 is exactly to to be deployed
so um there is an expectation that there
will be further application even from
within the council to the fund to
determine what is that's going to be
spent on so um your expectation that
there will be further work done and
further proposals put are real and that
will
happen councilor Mrs
gy I'd just like to ask either um Mr
Willis or or councelor hoy um is the
budget that has been put forward for the
walking and cycling enhancements to
Cherry Orchard is that going to be
sufficient to do what we're plan what's
written in the plan
there any any ters to I can uh give an
answer from my perspective yeah thank
you um thank you which would be in in
order to respect the budget that is
allocated whatever that may end up being
the amount of work that he's carried out
at Cherry Orchard will only be as far as
the budget
allows that was another way of what I
said earlier but nevertheless it was far
more elegant and I thank
you any further questions
members there aren't any um so councilor
Hoy do you want to lead us through the
recommendations please thank you
chairman you're welcome I will read out
the recommendations R1 to
R3 recommendation one that Authority be
delegated to the Strategic director in
consultation with the lead member for
resources climate change and economy to
operate a community grant program funded
by an allocation of up to £250,000 of
the council's 20242 5 UKF
allocation R2 that Authority be
delegated to the Strategic director in
consultation with the lead member for
resources climate change and economy to
spend the remaining proportion of the
council's 20242 ukp sorry I got it wrong
then UK PS sorry it's written down
wrongly in the report that's my problem
UK SPF allocation in Broad alignment
with provisions of appendix B R3 that
the Strategic director be asked to
provide quartly updates to the executive
concerning the latest position of UK SPF
expenditure plans and to invite the
executive to advise should any
significant change of circumstances
arise so recommendations are proposed by
councilor Michael Hoy do we have a
second thank you very much councelor Mrs
goody um do you agree that we can take
all three recommendations in one vote
okay in which case I'll I'll invite you
to show on the show of hands to show
those in favor
please that is also
unanimous thank you members and members
of the public um I believe we've now
completed the agenda I would like to
thank you for your attendance and I
close the meeting at
822 thank you Council new Point thank
you